[Music]
jurassic world fallen kingdom contained
some pretty shocking revelations but the
2018 sequel ended on a cliffhanger
leaving us with more questions than
answers
we've done some digging and we think we
know where the third installment might
be heading
here's everything we know about jurassic
world 3 so far
in 2017 colin trevaro was fired from
star wars the rise of skywalker over
creative differences
despite the fact that he'd already
dedicated two years of his life to the
project
lucasfilm came to the conclusion that
trevorrow just wasn't the right fit for
star wars and replaced him with jj
abrams but when it comes to the jurassic
movies
he's the go-to guy trevor only had
one theatrical feature on his resume
when he was chosen to helm 2015's
jurassic world
his critically acclaimed time travel
caper safety not guaranteed
despite a lack of blockbuster experience
the director handled the summer tentpole
like a seasoned pro
impressing the man behind the movie that
started it all during an april 2018
interview with entertainment weekly
trevaro revealed that steven spielberg
personally asked him to take charge of
jurassic world 3
an offer that he simply couldn't refuse
steven spielberg
asked me to direct and when he asks you
what can i tell you man
in all honesty over my past few years
i've grown to love and cherish the value
of the gift that i've been given with
this franchise
interestingly trevorrow only came on
board the franchise
after j.a bayona turned down the chance
to direct jurassic world
bayonna took the reigns for 2018
follow-up jurassic world fallen kingdom
but spielberg wanted travarro back in
the hot seat for the all-important
third film which is due for release in
summer 2021
trevorrow is co-writing the picture with
pacific rim uprising's emily carmichael
which should make for a pretty
interesting mix of ideas
i just love the idea of of a dinosaur
biting the head off a robot i love that
too i was like that's so sweet
colin trevaro has confirmed that the
stars of the first two jurassic world
movies will be back in action for the
third film
marvel man chris pratt returns as
dinosaur researcher owen grady while
bryce dallas howard reprises the role of
former park operations manager claire
dearing
speaking to entertainment weekly ahead
of jurassic world fallen kingdom's
official release the director indicated
that a number of characters from the
second movie could end up playing a big
role in jurassic world 3. travaro said
there's other characters who will meet
in fallen kingdom
you'll realize are major characters now
that we've seen jurassic world fallen
kingdom
we think we know just who trevaro was
talking about
isabella's sermon will most likely be
back as maisie lockwood the genetically
engineered granddaughter of john
hammond's murdered business associate
benjamin lockwood
with nowhere else to go at the end of
fallen kingdom maisy rides off into the
sunset with owen and claire
who seemingly adopt the clone child as
their own
she basically sets up the entire premise
of jurassic world 3 when she releases
the cloned dinosaurs
i had to their life
like me so maisy is bound to have a
substantial role in the upcoming sequel
daniella pineda's dinovet zia rodriguez
and justice smith's constantly terrified
systems analyst franklin
webb also escaped isla nublar with their
lives
so both characters could feasibly pop up
in jurassic world 3.
could sam neil laura dern and jeff
goldblum return as alan grant
ellie sattler and ian malcolm in
jurassic world three
all three actors have reprised their
respective roles since debuting in
jurassic park
but they haven't been in the same entry
since they appeared together in the
franchise opener back in 1993.
goldblum popped up most recently though
his part in jurassic world falling
kingdom
was little more than a glorified cameo
with one really cool line
we've entered a new era
[Music]
welcome to jurassic world judging by the
comments that goldblum made while he was
a guest on watch what happens live in
2018
this contrived committee scene won't be
the last time we see dr malcolm
there's going to be another one which
you know some people may or may not be
and that's all i can say goldblum had
previously hinted that laura dern might
be getting back in her khakis for
jurassic world three
something the star wars actress is
clearly keen on when she spoke to
deadline in 2018
durn said it's a good time for powerful
feminist characters to be honored
i love ellie i love her and i love
dinosaurs
and there is something extraordinary
about getting to live out something that
we all carry from childhood
during a 2019 appearance on good morning
america durn was asked by none other
than bryce dallas howard if she would
consider returning to the franchise
and her response made it sound like
she's basically waiting to be asked
do you know something i may not and
if i were to would you join me
bryce dallas howard has been pretty
vocal about her desire to work with the
stars of the original jurassic park
movie
the actress was quizzed about the
chances of them coming back for one last
expedition while she was promoting elton
john biopic rocket man
and she seemed to indicate that it was
definitely in the pipeline
she said i don't know what's been
confirmed or whatever but i'll blink if
it's happening
the return of neil dern and goldblum
would tie the sequel trilogy to the
original one
and it would no doubt go down well with
the franchise's enthusiastic fan base
when mtv suggested that some people
might feel robbed if no legacy
characters show up in jurassic world 3
colin trevaro gave an encouraging
response the director said
i totally agree with that i would feel
robbed
too the jurassic world franchise is in
need of a new villain
we've seen the last of the conniving eli
mills who became a light snack for rexy
in jurassic world fallen kingdom
and vic hoskins is also history ripped
apart by a raptor towards the end of
jurassic world
that means there's going to be a brand
new villain in jurassic world 3 but that
doesn't necessarily mean a brand new
character
dr henry wu is the man responsible for
bringing the dinosaurs back to life in
franchise
lore he was john hammond's go-to
geneticist in jurassic park and he
continued his morally ambiguous work in
the sequel trilogy
wu survived the events of the first two
jurassic world films and there's a
chance that he'll go full villain
in the trilogy closer nerdist wants to
see this happen
calling for a quote powerful resolution
for the character
john hammond's legacy is always present
in the jurassic world films
but no living character connects the new
trilogy to the original film
like bd wong's dr henry wu he's the
walter white of jurassic park
which is why he's now the most
interesting character in the franchise
we have a history with wu we have
questions about how he got to this point
and we want to see where it leads him
especially after the end of fallen
kingdom
left all of humanity at risk of
extinction
colin trevorrow has indicated that
numerous characters from jurassic world
fallen kingdom will appear in jurassic
world 3.
but what about the supporting players
from jurassic world
jake johnson put in a scene stealing
performance as laurie cruthers in the
2015 film
and the news that he wouldn't be
returning for fallen kingdom was a blow
for fans of the easy-going control room
worker
when trevor sat down for an interview
with den of geek he explained why
johnson wasn't in the second jurassic
world movie
and at the same time opened the door for
his return in the third one
trevorrow said he's not in jurassic
world 2 for the same reason that any
other
actor would be excluded from a movie
unless we can find a genuine organic way
to make it not seem like he's just
in it because he was a great character
in a previous film
it doesn't mean he'll never be back and
i've had conversations with almost
all of the actors going back to the
previous films about how
important their legacies are to these
movies and how important it is to
continuously change and evolve them
into something new 14 years passed
between jurassic park 3 and jurassic
world
but that long gap wasn't down to a lack
of trying
numerous sequels were reportedly floated
during that period
and the one that got the closest to
getting the green light came by way of
director and screenwriter john sales
sales jurassic park 4 never got off the
ground
but what's interesting is that a lot of
his ideas ended up being used in
jurassic world
and jurassic world fallen kingdom the
star of sales story was an unemployed
mercenary named
nick harris who seems very much like the
blueprint for chris pratt's ex-navy man
owen grady
most notably it was sales who came up
with the idea of shady types attempting
to train dinosaurs as weapons
which seems to be the overarching theme
of the jurassic world movies
if this unused screenplay influenced the
first and second jurassic world films
it could also contain clues about where
the third one is heading
the sail script taps into the idea of an
america plagued by rogue dinosaurs
with the country in crisis humans
weaponized dinosaurs in an effort to
stave off extinction
considering everything we've seen so far
it isn't hard to imagine jurassic world
3 playing out along these lines
he wouldn't give an inch when it came to
plot details but jurassic world three's
leading man
chris pratt said that the movie was
definitely going to deliver when he sat
down with mtv's josh horowitz in
february 2019.
i can't say anything but i can tell you
when i heard the pitch
i was blown away and i
i mean i can't believe that we're gonna
make that movie the actor is clearly on
board with whatever it is that writer
director colin trevaro has planned
calling the story quote pretty epic
pratt went on to say
i can't believe they found a way to
deliver on the promise of the end of
jurassic world fallen kingdom
the island has blown up the animals are
out
we can't put them back in the box what
are we going to do
how are not only these dinosaurs but
this technology moving forward going to
affect the planet
the co-star of the franchise also
confirmed that there would be a time
jump between
fallen kingdom and jurassic world 3. and
we jump forward it's like
oh oh right oh
damn giving further credence to the idea
that jurassic world 3 will take place in
an america
overrun with dinosaurs the vision first
put forward by john sayles
this scenario means that isabella
sermon's maisy lockwood will be older
and
wiser than the last time we saw her she
freed the dinosaurs at the end of the
previous movie
will she take their side again in
jurassic world 3
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more videos about
jurassic world 3 are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you